what comes to your mind when you think
of Muslims do you put them in a box
based on biases heard from the media
your peers are just unknown sources as
you play along this episode of odd man
out
think of how you pick them we brought
together seven Muslims I'm Muslim I'm
Muslim I am Muslim
I'm us I'm Muslim I'm I'm Muslim one is
a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll split a cash prize if the liar
survives they win the entire prize
[Music]
also there's a surprise this episode not
that the cast is all moles but for the
first time the prize money will decrease
for each round the players continue
passed around to where we're like the
families are in Pakistan Karachi oh
crotchety yeah I'm also focused on
YouTube from Karachi as well I mean my
family were just from New York but I
know that my grandfather had a converted
to Muslim I'm Palestinian parents
foreign raised their first generation
I'm Jordanian which is next to Palestine
yeah I lived in a man for two years I
just came from I'm mine like two years
and a half ago oh cool cool so I'm new
here in the States
yeah Bangladesh okay see what my parents
are from first generation as well how
did your family implement Islam growing
up al Baba was asking a lot of questions
and she was kind of trying to get
information out of the others so I
suspected that my community growing up
was in there was a lot of you know white
people with you know people and I always
felt like I was only Muslim now I relate
to that too because like I mean like I'm
african-american you know so like I
think it's like not expected of me it's
a V but growing up like that's just what
I was talking like for my father my
grandfather you know after my father had
passed away you know like it made me
like look at everything he told ya know
so I got right back into it yeah I mean
growing up most of my mom's white so it
was kind of like a half culture you know
when I did the Sunday School thing and I
like finished the Quran twice it wasn't
I was like strict Muslim I come from a
Muslim family my mom is not strict
however she wears hijab but she never
enforced it on us like she always they
tell us when it's the right time for you
and you feel it within your heart that
you want to wear hijab
then you're gonna wear hijab I was
looking for like little clues and I know
with like Zana
she wore an evil eye and like my mom
taught me that in this LOM like the evil
eye like you're not supposed to wear
that what's it like being Muslim
presence we found like the hardest thing
being Muslim at least maybe here being
Muslim for me it's funny because you
know I'm very liberal I guess in a way
it's hard because some people again just
put you in a box and they're like me but
you're not wearing a job and you know
you wear tank tops my mom was happy job
I've always kind of envied that like she
can wear her slam like publicly outside
because like sometimes I'll see another
lady walking down the street wearing a
hijab and I want to say some are late
home bye don't want to be like some
random guy who she might like be afraid
of on the street just trying to talk to
her for high school I went to a Catholic
all guys school so that was very
different
I didn't like when he mentioned that he
went to a Catholic school I was a bit
thrown off because you would assume that
they would go to a school based off of
their religion it was like it was a
school that was close by and my mom like
wanted me to like all boys I don't want
like you with girls around kind of thing
and for her it was just it's still like
it's another religious institution
that's going to be teaching like similar
values and just like morals kind of
stuff you know she didn't get to really
talk a lot and again she said she was
like you know half white and so it
seemed very obvious
I'm vanilla because I'm halfway I think
it definitely made people suspicious of
me because I don't love Pakistani at all
so they'd probably think that I was
lying when I told them that okay I think
you should have like more factual yeah
yeah it's like what it's like fasting
what it feels like for you what your
family does that's like being around
people who are not like doing it you
know I'm saying it's like watching
people eat for me it like helps like I
don't know why you're watching Food
Network torture kind of thing cars oh
I've heard from like my family back home
to at least like it is this case in
Karachi but like what's nice is that is
diner Madonn they closed the restaurants
instead yeah until iftar so it makes it
even easier for you to like go ahead and
still practice because you know
sometimes you're out like go out with
your friends and eat like not eat but
like just wash them and don't be like I
don't want it here in front of you are
you okay Lisa Ramadan like it was a time
when I was a bit younger and
I was in high school and I was going
through legal very like rebellious time
yeah it was during Ramadan why I just
like I had this like realization like
I'm not doing the right thing right now
no it was that time but I really like
transform was the reason I was
suspicious about Yaron I feel like any
time when I'd peek around I just saw him
like scanning everybody kind of looking
a little fidgety someone would say
something and then he'd be oh yeah me
too I tried it fast at least like three
to four days out of the week just to
kind of give myself that opportunity to
do it there was one month I did it
everyday ones like the best of all I
thought like I would it was hard for me
when I was younger too fast all the days
no alcohol or like no pork do you guys
like feel strongly about one thing about
Islam it or but like not about the
others I mean I feel I feel very
strongly about it like not eating for it
I just remember you know that's like
something that my father really like
like told me you know like yeah like
pour juice wine you know so yeah like I
stay like completely away from it you
know I mean yeah conversations with my
mom we'd be like if like a law came down
right now gross like that's a little
yeah
for me I also think that no alcohol
thing is pretty big from as i dang it
felt like there was more pressure to
more purchased to find the mold quicker
and I didn't I feel like I wanted to get
into some deeper questions
like honestly I went to ten how devout
do you guys think you are okay for me
around six years ago I had a very bad
car accident and I was almost dead like
I stayed in the hospital for three
months and have a scar in my face now if
you can see it was a very bad experience
however it got me closer to Allah
a car hit us and I had to go through the
front window I thank God I'm alive that
I'm healthy that there's nothing wrong I
say like I'm like a five because I don't
really have anyone like that's like no
it's not like but then like my family
big like that you know say the lessons
that that were taught you know I'm
saying this I I embody those maybe not
all the you know the other things that
come with it you know we talked about an
experience where you encountered someone
that was down for me it was maybe I
think my sophomore year of high school I
got this one sweatshirt that like had an
Arabic written Russia India doomed and
under in English this too shall pass and
some random kid who I didn't know like
skates up to me and says like oh so
you're a terrorist I was just like
taking it back of the excuse me I think
I was like 14 but that was like the
first time for me that I really like
experienced and was just a little like
whoa like where's this come from this
kid looked like he was 12 he looked
younger than me but he already has his
ideas of like oh you're a terrorist just
because you have like maybe some Arabic
written on your sweatshirt almost every
time I've gone to the airport where
there wasn't with my family or by myself
and any of us would be pulled to the
side for a little random search there is
definite kind of prejudice involved in
that I believe it was basically in lay
it was in middle school and we were a PE
class and it key goes up to me and I
think because you heard my last name he
just like he called me he called me a
terrorist and I completely lost myself
and start cursing at him and then
afterwards I had this whole realization
like
why were you put into a cat
honestly it was three minutes from our
house I'm my parents wanted a school
that would teach similar values are you
a Muslim one listen like what's the
biggest thing to you that means that
you're Muslim so I was hijab in high
school but then when I entered like UCLA
I took off my scarf but I think that
because of this I actually grew closer
to the Sun would you mind listing all
five prayers I'm like one in the day
that they have been doing what I don't
know why I'm on the spot right now but
you know it's that it's all crap just
like warning you know I watched my dad
do it a lot you know what was like to
point that we do like that turn you to
you know find a lot a bit more I guess
oh yeah I mean I was just like partying
a lot a lot of like the bad things like
and my whole family's religious so my
Bangladesh like you you won't meet up in
golly that's not what how can you be
exempt from fasting do you know yes of
course yeah okay if you are a very sick
and you are under medication and
threatening your life you should not
fast especially for other people
[Music]
like my gut instinct was aina and so I
wish I always said if it's too well it's
got to be her she fit the character very
well but the reason why I didn't go
further with it was because I had met
Muslims who are like her no but I really
want to tell you the truth I know a lot
of Quran I've said you put on were you
raised up in another religion no no no
no I'm I'm Christian but but but but but
we are only two percent out of the
population Jordan we're very very late
[Music]
it was kind of I felt bad because
they're all nice because I know I'm a
liar and they're always super sweet you
know I'm not as knowledgeable and I'm
not I have tattoos you know I don't
follow necessarily the guidelines I'm a
strict with it you know I just know that
it's a personal relationship we all have
our own like ways we practice and we
understand that just because somebody
practices it a little bit less or a
little bit more doesn't make them any
more of a Muslim than the other person
hi my name is Rodney bhasin and I
directed this episode of odd man out and
if you would like to play along in the
next episode you can go to our Instagram
page and vote for who you think the mole
is until next time one myth that I don't
didn't come from my teacher it came from
a lot of seventh graders for some reason
and they're like oh people getting
choked for kissing in the halls I'm like
gee I am a middle schooler I'm a middle
schooler I am a middle schooler I'm a
middle schooler I'm a middle schooler
I'm a middle school I'm a middle
schooler one is a fifth grader
[Music]